[Music]
[Applause]
NBC Sports host and uh he is the host of
Sunday Night Football the play-by-play
voice and covering the Open Championship
the 151st Open championship at Royal
Liverpool he's Mike Tirico and coverage
will start NBC at 7 A.M Eastern Mike
calling his 25th Open Championship what
was it like when you called your first
one
I wish I remember man it was 97 it was a
long time ago Justin Leonard won uh I I
don't think I knew what I was doing at
that point calling golf I only called
the four or five events but I do
remember Justin had a great Sunday yeah
a steady Sunday hope you guys had a
chance to catch him and Justin was here
on his own it wasn't a big family or
girlfriend or wife at the time it was
just Justin and his caddy ordering a
pizza after winning the open it was it
was pretty cool pretty cool scene we got
to relive that a few times and work with
Justin over the last couple years here
so that was kind of cool but I'm
wondering when when it comes to an
audience knowing terminology you know
because if you call it a sand trap or a
bunker and then you know the golf uh
cognacentes is going to come right after
you there but football or horse racing
give me the sport where you got to stay
in your lane and be careful because
they're there to correct you
probably golf early on because so many
of the participants or the viewers are
participants they play all the time you
know your members at a club you play
with your foursome every week you have a
certain time you play on weekends so I I
think probably golf as much as any
because the people who are watching they
know the language they play and you can
tell a fraud right away somebody doesn't
know the support fortunately I played
not well but played at that time so it
wasn't like it was all brand new to me
but uh I I think Dan if I knew then
what a career pivot point that what
might have been I don't know if I
necessarily would have said yeah I'm
going to do this but I was lucky I was
surrounded by Kurdish strange Judy
Rankin Bob Rossford Steve Melnick some
really good and talented people that
kind of kept me in a place where I could
succeed early on and you know 25 opens
in 27 years of doing this later it's uh
it's fun to be the old guy I guess every
once in a while do you remember when the
story came out that I was up for the job
to do golf
oh you know what I've forgotten about
that yes right yeah so why didn't you
um I I never talked to anybody other
than it was in Rudy martskey's column in
USA Today I'm getting ready to do the 11
o'clock Sports Center
and one of our bosses realizes the next
day that it's going to be made official
that you're going to be the voice of
golf for ABC okay
this is a 96. okay I'm walking down to
the set and one of our former bosses go
uh hey can you come here I you know I
got five minutes to get from one
building to the other to do Sports
Center calls me in and he goes hey
um
tariko's going to get the golf job
and I go
what yeah he goes yeah
tariko's going to do golf uh and uh and
and you're you're going to just stay
doing SportsCenter
I then have to go over and do a sports
center after I just had that and and it
was one of those moments where I go
I didn't I didn't volunteer I didn't ask
I was just told that I was up for the
job but it's interesting yeah yeah so
you I stole it Friday
I'm sure I did uh because because you
were clamoring I did uh two two Senior
Tour events in 96 and uh those are the
first two opportunities I had to do golf
I actually got the chance to do it
because Jim Kelly not the Bills
quarterback but Jim Kelly was a terrific
sportscaster but a bunch of assignments
he was doing the America's Cup
in San Diego and uh they needed somebody
to fill in I did I did two golf events
with Andy North and Gary Koch and Bob
Murphy and those guys those guys were uh
were God sentence for me to to help get
started so so maybe you would be here
and I'd be sitting here right now it was
different if Rudy would have gotten it
right what would you shoot on that
course right now if you were playing oh
my God it certainly begins with a one uh
okay you know I'm I'm a 14 so I'm in the
high 80s low 90s if um if I'm playing my
average I can shoot a little better I
have shot a lot worse including the last
couple of weeks I can't drive it right
now uh but I'd love to see 10 15 index
players come out and try to play these
courses because you're shooting triple
digits it's so hard it's so fine you
know you're not raking it up from Two
and a half feet that's good yeah
you gotta pull everything out and you're
gonna miss a few of those this course
like all these courses for the open it's
the wind if we get some wind then you
really have a story and I was just up on
the 14th team with Rory McIlroy Cheryl
Hatton Tommy Fleetwood and Victor
hovland and it's a practice route you
guys need a couple of balls Rory put a
two hour in the Fairway the other three
guys hit two drivers and out of the six
drives missed the Fairway and then now
you're hitting it out of rough EA high
and all that so it takes forever and
would be a high number for most average
players but are you rooting for that as
a broadcaster of yeah do you want the
weather you want the conditions you want
us to almost feel it as we're watching
this I think you want some but on
Thursday and Friday you'd like it to be
fair
because you can get play early Thursday
weather is good
front or a storm or winds coming in
Thursday night Friday morning so the
guys who go late Thursday early Friday
they just get a raw deal with the draw
and then guys in that half it's pretty
balanced with good players guys in that
half of the draw just get taken out of
the tournament as long as it's fair to
get you to the weekend but I think this
major more than anything else begs for a
little rain a little wet a little
weather a little wind if you sit and
watch the open you get up early to watch
it you just want to see people fight I
mean the whole world is experiencing
record heat right now and it was 63
degrees here yesterday I was two layers
walking around the golf course it was a
cold rain and it's just different and I
think that's why this open and this
major I should say has um has stayed
with its unique power to connect with
American fans because we don't see golf
or conditions like this very often he's
Mike Tirico NBC Sports host play-by-play
voice of Sunday Night Football Patrick
Cantley and Brooks koepka are paired
together and bro books played with
Patrick Cantley before and said it was
death because he takes forever now I
know they manipulate the you know the
pairings here do you think that they did
this on purpose to put Brooks kepco with
Patrick Cantley with the possibility of
somebody being murdered
I don't think that's the outcome that
they saw oh okay okay but but there's
always been a little bit of a sense of
humor to put some of these groupings
together and Thursday and Friday and I
don't know if it was humor or if it was
just yeah we're gonna put them together
uh but here it is and
it's hard kepca has said it publicly
right yeah and Patrick Hanley is not a
fast player so
is Brooks already slightly defeated in
terms of his mental approach I don't
think so because the majors he blocks
him out he loves play but he he'll be
unhappy if Patrick is taking forever and
it's a slow day and Majors can get slow
if there's a little bit of wind there's
a backup on a par five somebody's making
an eight needs a ruling it can slow down
it can take five hours
Brooks can run a little hot in those
situations is he strong enough to forget
about it and just play I'll tell you the
one thing you'll see
if can't wait plays first and then kept
the plays and it could often be the case
because Brooks hits it so far man as
soon as that ball lands the other guy
Brooks is over it right in fire he's
like he's a hard guy for the golf
producer on the TV side but you got to
be ready because Brooks is going to fire
as soon as that ball comes to a stop
how much is tape and how much is live
when you're doing play-by-play
it depends on who's producing at the
different networks it also depends on
the flow of the golf course
if you go to commercial you've got to
come back and get caught up because the
action so once where the action doesn't
stop right during breaks the other thing
I think people
should realize it's easy to be critical
of what's on tape what's live and there
could be 40 golf balls in motion at the
same time if no other sport do you have
anything more than one ball in motion at
one time so you've got all these choices
so while you're playing fritzy well
maybe that's a bad example of friction
somebody else might be hitting a shot
right so you're playing I'm watching you
live and you're a slower player but I'm
staying over because you've got an eagle
putt that means I'm missing two shots
that I'd like to show so you should I
think the audience should accept use
coming back and saying hey this this was
while Dan was playing here are these two
shots I'd say that the later you get
into the weekend the more is live
because there are less shots you have to
show but on Thursday and Friday those
feature groups the main groups like we
have uh Rory RAM and Rose together right
before 10 a.m eastern time you'll see a
lot of their stuff live a lot of the
other stuff around them will be taped
because you're watching those three guys
play so you got to balance it and figure
it out is there a more rooted floor
athlete right now than Rory McIlroy
given everything that's happened he was
the face of the PGA Tour stood up to the
live tour the Americans you know
appreciated this uh he's been playing
great just won the Scottish open
yeah I I don't want to just blurt it out
and say yes because that's my initial
reaction is yes for all the reasons you
just said I'm trying to think you know
outside of Kansas City Mahomes is
likable
Steph has a likable quality about him as
you saw with the uh event Lake Tahoe the
American Century right it was like that
was really cool the reaction on social
media the steps hole in one was wow
that's that was pretty awesome but
they've won recently
yeah exactly but I I would I would say
yes and here's why I'd say yes with
worry
Tiger's not in the not in the mix right
now Rory probably moves the meter in
terms of ratings as much as any golfer
in the UA for American fans and he's not
American
he was in Scotland
taking the Scottish open title with
back-to-back birdies in the last two
holes out of the hands of a Scott yeah
Scottish players don't win and the crowd
went nuts it wasn't like oh polite
Applause great player one he took it
from our guy they were going crazy that
tells you how popular he is up on the
14th tee uh if Rory heard his name 70
times about an hour ago when I was up
there with him that's that's a low
estimate uh I would say certainly in
Dolphin as I just go through the sports
probably as popular globally as any guy
is right now but for the reasons you
mentioned he stood by his word turned
down 600 700 million dollars to stay
true to his word that resonates I think
with fans in 2023. I'll leave you with
this because people brought this up some
people on this show brought it up hey
could you see Steph Curry maybe when
he's done playing basketball at the age
of 39 or 40
playing like a corn fairy tour something
like that and I said yes you know but
there's a difference between being a
scratch golfer and being a professional
golfer and Steph Curry you know barely
beat out Marty fish and nobody's going
hey could Marty fish play on the corn
fairy tour well we saw smokes play yeah
right yeah and he did okay right and
Tony Romo
and Tony Romo and Steph is a phenomenal
athlete and he is still young enough at
this point right and in great shape
hasn't taken the beating that Tony took
physically right
and Steph is so good right now as he is
a top level active player in his sport
so yeah you're going to get some
degradation with a few years but let's
now say that this great athlete is
putting all of that time instead of into
shooting
into his golf game because his golf
games at a pretty high level these other
guys are really really good and they do
it under pressure I think that's the
difference Dan you can get a good golfer
but around a crowd they're not as good I
think a crowd makes a guy like Steph
better yeah I think he thrives on that
yeah pressure in the moment and all that
so I'd say he could he could play I
don't know if he could play on the corn
Ferry tour and prove himself over time
but if you put him in an event I think I
think he'd do all right especially after
he was done playing as basketball a
traditional meal that you've had the
best meal you've had there of local fare
yeah fish and chips I mean you have to
have fish and chips now we're not in
Scotland because you could have haggis
and I know that you know what haggis is
I'm sure you've had haggis blood pudding
have you had blood pudding I've had
blood pudding in Scotland but we're not
in Scotland so I can avoid those
Delicacies I I I I've I don't know 25
years of doing the open I've never done
the broadcast in a kilt
you've worn a kilt on the air haven't
you yeah I got one on right now
obviously of course you do yeah for the
segment yeah I'd ask you if you have
anything else on under them however
we're out of time for the segment from
yes because because you're doing Golf
and I'm not
you're in the cave
Legends of the business behind you what
more could a man ask for you've got the
USA thing up over your head and in case
anybody tuned in didn't know you're an
American we know that it's perfect
have fun Mike
That's Mike Tarico he's uh covering the
uh 151st Open championship